hey guys pete here it's time for the
fargo season 4 episode 5 breakdown
and we lost one of the good ones the
birthplace of civilization
delivers escalation on all fronts of the
impending war between the fadas and loy
cannon's outfit
we get some backstory details some
violence
some connections to past seasons and an
awful lot of monologuing about america
all the necessary ingredients are there
including a big character moment to
close things out but still
somehow the episode manages to feel like
something's missing
i'll get into my thoughts about that
after i recap the events of episode 5.
this will include spoilers so if you
haven't watched the episode yet this is
your warning hit the subscribe button
go get caught up and then come back to
watch the breakdown
and with that out of the way let's dive
in because there is a lot to cover
one thing episode 5 doesn't have a lot
of is orienta
there's just one scene she's at work
with a patient who's moaning in agony
she shushes him and when that doesn't
quiet him down she resorts to banging
her head against the wall
the scene is intertwined with ethel rita
working on a letter in her room
she's definitely thinking of turning
orienta in
putting pen to paper to alert her boss
dr harvard
about the nurse's hobby of killing off
patients in her care
we don't find out if she actually sends
the letter though
her father comes in to put her to bed
and ends up giving up the location of
anzel mayer
in the process he tells her not to go
looking for the fugitives and adds that
she probably shouldn't be hanging out
with orienta
since he thinks she might have poisoned
the pie that was left on their doorstep
the birthday girl doesn't listen to her
dad though the next day she makes her
way to the new perry hotel
she's looking for advice and asks her
aunt who's trying to celebrate her
birthday with a drink of whiskey
what she would do if she saw something
wrong zelmer answers flatly that she
wouldn't do
anything and this leads to an
explanation of how they're not
criminals their outlaws criminals play
the game
while they break the rules of society
they still operate
inside of it outlaws reject the game
outright and therefore have no rules
their crime is freedom when pressed on
what she is
the girl says that she's etherida pearl
smutny
she's one of a kind i think this is
probably one of the strongest parts of
the episode and when we see rules being
imposed on them
later it underlines the situation that
most of the characters of the story find
themselves in
loy is the one that's going to act as
the rules and poser and he starts off
the episode handing off his stolen
thought of guns
last week he mentioned morty kellerman
and this week we see him in the flesh
it's a direct connection to the opening
flashback in the fourth episode of
season 2
which took place in 1951 when that's
taken care of he wants his guys to head
over to his new funeral home
to persuade the previous owners the
smutnies to give up the location of the
women who robbed him
that's all interrupted by otis who
enters the garage with a group of police
officers
they arrest some of his crew otis takes
the bag of cash that loy was carrying
and we find out that he knows about the
detective's time in the war which i'll
come back to
on his way out otis delivers the message
to stick with the deal from the fadas
josto is also making moves he's trying
to show his brother gaetano the right
way to get things done
he has the police raided jazz club where
lloyd's oldest son lemuel's hanging out
getting him roughed up and arrested
later at the fada house he talks
strategy with rabbi milligan
who's helping satchel with his math
homework josto thinks that his plan will
work to get the cannons to
back down and then with no war to fight
gaetano will head back home to italy
rabbi disagrees on both points telling
him that his brother is there to take
over
he warns him that his problem is a math
problem he has to divide his
enemies or the multiply after josto
leaves the room rabbi tells satchel to
be ready
saying when the shooting starts we
vanish this seems to add more credence
to the idea that we're looking at a
young mike milligan from season 2.
later josto pays a visit to the jail
where a large number of loys men
are currently being held he delivers a
speech explaining that americans like a
crime story because america
is a crime story he says see johnny
society
looks at me and they see a fella that's
using crime to get ahead
but you all they see is crime and that's
why you're going to lose
rabbi lingers for a minute after he
leaves trying to find out how they think
loy will respond
he tells them to let their boss know
that he'll keep his boys safe
no matter what marshall deffy shows up
at otis place
after seeing him raid the cannons the
night before
looking around his place he notices a
photo of a woman on the
wall we learn this is his fiancee who
was
raped and murdered while he was away
fighting in the war
it ties into what loy was saying at the
warehouse earlier
there we find out that one of otis's
superior
officers stepped on a mine in a field he
said he'd swept
he took it as otis folding under the
pressure and not being able to do his
job
when really he'd been laying in the
grass not clearing the minds because he
learned about his fiance's murder
otis doesn't want to go with him so
deffy heads to ethelrita school alone
he lays out the crimes that zelmer and
swanny committed which landed them in
prison
the teenager looked surprised to hear
that her aunt killed a pregnant woman
and her husband for less than ten
dollars and that swanny was involved in
a bank robbery where a father of three
is killed still she holds her ground at
first and even fights back some when he
suggests that she should act in a
civilized manner
picking up on the implied racism she
responds
civilized you know do you not that
africa
is the birthplace of civilization which
means both your ancestors and mine
came from the same green savannah after
that he just goes straight to
threatening he threatens to have her
expelled if she doesn't give up where
her aunt's hiding out
and then he makes his way to the new
paris we find out that lloyd's also on
his way there
after an argument at home with his wife
he pays a visit to thurman and dubrell
at the king of tears
he explains that he knows they paid him
with his own money
and that he knows her sister was behind
the robbery paying him with his own
money
is actually news to the brell and she
tries to negotiate a solution
but loy isn't sympathetic to their
situation because he knows he has the
upper hand
thurman starts to unravel saying he
didn't know where the money came from
and when lloyd threatens their lives
and ethereda's life they know they have
to tell him about the hotel
defi is racing through town to get there
and it looks like there might be a big
confrontation brewing if they all arrive
at the same time
instead loy arrives first after some
discussion about the reality of their
situation he's able to turn the
self-described outlaws to his side
there's a moment where swanny pushes him
to either kill them or rape them where
he says
dying is too easy they owe him and he's
putting them to work
he says he needs some invisible soldiers
the other side won't be able to see
coming and this does make sense from his
perspective
overall we see him doing a pretty good
job of taking care of things exerting
his power and control where he can but
these two probably aren't going to work
out the way he's hoping for
in an effort to get things in order he's
inviting a couple agents of chaos into
his operation
and on the subject to chaos i haven't
gotten to gaitano yet
he spent most of the episode with
constant and it would seem that he's
been in the u.s long enough to develop
his thesis about what's wrong with
americans
he delivers this in an interaction with
an unlucky waiter who happened to be
outside taking a smoke break right in
time to witness one of the episodes
undeniably funny moments he watches as
gaetano slips on the ice and with the
way it's set up you know his being there
is gonna cost him dearly
he meets his end after serving a subpar
cup of coffee to the italian
the scene serves to reinforce all the
things we put together about gaetano
and shows that he's fully capable of
carrying out violence himself
rather than just ordering someone else
to do it he then makes his way over to
spuds all time
where dr senator is surprised to see
them instead of abel
guytano just sort of sits in the back
and eats a sundae
constant delivers his origin story about
arriving as a baby
in a box after his mother died on the
way to america
the point being that there's nothing
tougher than an orphan who had to bring
himself
up from that situation all things
considered it's not bad for an origin
story
but i think what really defines this
scene is
dr senator he pretty much knows what's
going down here
and we watch as he goes through the
motions of having this conversation
listening responding interacting with
the waitress
all while playing out the different
scenarios of how he might get out of
this situation in one piece
he manages to deliver the final word as
it were saying
i don't know how they do it in your
country but in america respect is earned
continuing you you're just boys making a
mess
that one day i'm gonna have to clean up
of course that there would be a chance
for that to happen
turns out to be wishful thinking instead
constant guns him down in the street
bringing his story to an end
sometime later after night falls loy
arrives at the scene standing over his
dead body
it's clear that this hits him hard but
as the sound of sirens pick up they have
to leave the scene
and they have to leave his body behind
in a story where we know
most of these characters are going to
die it shouldn't be surprising to see dr
center to go but he was a standout
character built on a standout
performance so it is sad to see him go
at the very same time this scene serves
to highlight a problem with the season
that i've been having a hard time
putting into words
it's put together well the look the
dialogue the photography
it's all top notch but the scene doesn't
hit in a way that comes off as an
exclamation point at the end of a great
episode it's as if the whole of this
season so far
isn't equal to the sum of all its parts
rather than feeling tight and moving
confidently towards something it feels
like a bunch of individual scenes thrown
together
and that's not to say it's terrible i'm
not going to stop
watching but it feels like it could be
better instead of being glued to the
screen throughout and then
left wanting to dive back into what i
just saw
i find myself looking at the different
things that happen
thinking well that's actually pretty
good and looking for ways to tell myself
i enjoyed what i just watched
as a fan i really hope the back half of
this season can sort it out
there are a couple things that might be
reasons for why it's happening
the pandemic did interrupt production
things got
pushed back post-production was probably
affected by working remotely
i've also read that it turned out that
they had too much to fit into 10
episodes which meant that they had to
add another one at the last minute
that's not something that you usually
hear and that could have caused
problems for the natural ending points
of the individual episodes
regardless from my perspective the
pacing and the momentum of things feels
off
there's a lot going on most of which is
darn interesting with
the potential to pay off but these early
episodes haven't been building the
anticipation and confidence in where
things are going in the way i would have
expected
one particular example i'll point out is
this interaction at the jail i don't
think it
landed the way it was supposed to the
idea behind it's fine
that even though they're all looked down
on the canons have the worst of it based
on the color of their skin
but it's not like josto's providing some
new insights here
the guys in the cell already know this
as viewers we already know this
so while what he says is enjoyable on
the surface
americans like a crime story because
america is a crime story
it's just sort of there it's just sort
of another thing that's said
as another thing happens it's kind of
the same with gaetano's murderous
rampage
and with the scene where lloyd blows up
on his wife
they're just sort of thrown in there and
i don't know that they accomplished what
they're supposed
to and there are so many things to like
in this episode i really enjoy the back
and forth between zelmer and swany
i really like the idea that nobody says
they're bad at english or nobody's proud
of it
the way that rabbi pointed this out to
josto and duffy and orienta pretty much
steal
every scene that they're in and i think
that's a good place to leave it because
that's where i'm at
i did notice a couple of nods to the
coen brothers here
morty kellerman's driving a truck that
says tree horn on the door which
is a call back to the big lebowski
jackie treehorn as you know
can make a hell of a white russian and
then of course we hear the fargo theme
after dr senator is killed for the first
time this season
and i think it really did add to this
scene so i'm curious where you're at
let me know in the comments what you
think what do you think of this season
so far what do you think about the
problems i'm having
how are you feeling about the future of
the season
do you think it's all going to come
together and what do you want to see as
that happens
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon